il ya une grosse difficultés sur
l'interprétation de ce qui se passe dans
une coop
parce que une coop ça rassemble
n'importe quoi entre 15000 et 40000
personnes
il ya des tas de gens qui disent qu'ils
négocient des tas de choses et en fait
avoir un jugement de synthèse sur ce qui
s'y passe est proche de la mission
impossible
la première fois que les chefs d'état se
sont mis d'accord sur la libye des 2°
c'était à copenhague et on a qualifié
cette coop d'échec à paris il ya un
certain nombre de gens qui sont arrivés
en disant voilà ce que je suis prêt à
faire ça permet pas de limiter la hausse
des températures à 2 degrés et on a
qualifié sa de succès donc j'ai envie de
vous dire que la ville jets sur la coque
23 ans n'a pas beaucoup d'importance est
pire que ça
le détail de ce qui a été acté à la coop
23 très rares sont les gens qui peuvent
avoir un avis circonstancié sur la
question il ya un moment où les limites
physiques de la planète vont se charger
de faire le ménage à notre place est
donc la seule chose qui est absolument
certaine c'est que si on ne gère pas le
processus on va avoir un nombre
croissant de surprise de plus en plus
désagréable